and I should also mention that there's
interesting writing now I'm not
obviously a scholar of Orwell and
there's a lot of books been written and
um I should probably recommend them
somewhere there's just great books
written on the on 1984 on on Orwell on
the historical context in which he was
operating and all that kind of stuff
but as far as I see Orwell also with
1984 and himself politically he was not
espousing the complete opposite of
totalitarianism there is a again
Democratic socialism that there is value
to the connection between human beings
that you have to lean on each other help
each other that Society is fundamentally
a cohesive Collective
then a
completely sort of
disparate set of Sovereign individuals
is both
and I think he was torn about that idea
because in order to resist the
totalitarian state you have to fight for
those basic individual freedoms but at
the same time a society a
well-functioning society allows for that
freedom to manifest as uh as
collaboration and so that's the
difficult challenge there again that's
why he was a Democratic Socialist and
the the criticism of the book was
against totalitarianism of a centralized
state that controls speech thought you
know the press and all the basic human
basic basic human freedoms controls
truth
and uh I think a lot of people would ask
the question and I hear this tossed
around you know do we live in the world
of 1984 today and I think that's used as
a shorthand to sort of criticize
different policies and different
governments
I generally don't like the use of that
kind of language because it's basically
crying wolf if everything is 1984 if
everybody is Hitler then you're not
going there's there's no way to kind of
uh
properly normalize the discussion of
what's uh of the lesser of two evils
kind of thing which is ultimately
democracy is about you have you have a
collection of things you're picking they
all kind of suck but you want to pick
the one that sucks the least that's
that's that's human society you know
that's human nature it's messy and so I
don't think we live in uh 1984 state but
there's a lot of elements that this book
reveals about human nature and about the
operation of a totalitarian state that
we should be on the watch for so
surveillance uh state of double think
of controlling language
um of being in a constant state of War
as a way to control the population and
the flow of resources all those things
have elements of uh almost like a useful
tools for the establishment of complete
control of a populace and the moment you
notice those elements it's our job to
resist those elements so I think the
point is we have to be vigilant to the
slippery slope of the will to power in
centralized institutions
another thing I I want to mention is
that
I think a lot of people rightfully
complement Orwell to have predict some
of the elements of future Society
especially with technology
technological capabilities
that are with for example telescreens
used by the state to control the
population maybe I can make a few
comments on technology in general
people who criticize technology will
often use 1984 as an example that
you know technology is a tool for
totalitarian state it's a way they can
achieve full control it should be
extremely cautious of it and I think
that's there's a kernel of Truth to that
but it's not obviously to me that on the
whole technology
is a a tool for totalitarian control
that I think it is also a tool for
freedom
the internet is an incredible tool for
freedom and so of course we have to
fight for that freedom but I believe in
general the greater let's just take the
internet broadly as an example and
there's a lot of sub elements of that
and like a more sort of platonic sense
of what the internet is which is digital
inter connectivity
we have to fight for the freedom but in
general the greater reach and access
that the internet has the more powerful
the resistance of totalitarianism
technology
is a double-edged sword
it provides the tools for oppression and
the tools for the ongoing fight for
freedom
and as long as the will to fight arises
in the human heart technology I think
helps Humanity win
and of course there's been a lot of
discussion about free speech and the
freedom of thought and there's a lot to
be said there that's much more nuanced
than the book 1984. provides I think
1984 just shows the end horrible
conclusion of complete totality and
control over speech over thought over
feeling over everything uh but in
general
my view of it is it's kind of
inspiration to in order to prevent
ourselves from slipping into an
authoritarian until uh totalitarian
state
you know orwellian type of dystopias to
avoid them we have to Value critical and
independent thought
I think thought first before speech just
thought
I think you have to learn to think
deeply from first principles independent
of whatever tribe you find yourselves in
independent of government independent of
groups and depending of the people
around you the people you love that love
you you have to learn at least sometimes
to think independently
now this is the niche if you gaze longer
to the abyss the abyss gazes into you if
you think too independently you can
break your mind I mean we are social
creatures we need that connection but I
think
it's like uh with the Tom Waits I like
my Tom a little Drop of Poison I think
of Truly Deeply independent thought as a
little Drop of Poison that's necessary
for your mind most of your life you live
you kind of assume most things around
you are true and that's very useful we
stand on the shoulders of giants but you
on a regular occasion have to question
question your assumption question your
biases question everything question the
things you've taken for granted question
what everybody's telling you but not too
much it's a it's a it's a tricky balance
but the act of rebellion against the
Italian State against the slippery slope
into that state is is that independent
thought and of course speech is a
manifestation of that thought So to
avoid Echo Chambers in both thought and
speech like I said you have to question
your assumptions challenge your biases
I think that's the way out or maybe
that's a resistance mechanism to uh
slipping into authoritarianism